all right good morning let's see so I
actually think of myself as an
accidental entrepreneur in many ways
because I didn't come out of college
thinking of myself as going off and
starting companies actually began in a
large company environment and in
hindsight realized that I was actually
doing very entrepreneurial things within
a market context of large company and so
from that experience and I gradually
worked my way down to doing this
succession of small startups and now
have a hard time imagining going back to
large company environment but that
experience has sort of caused me to
develop a theory that entrepreneurship
there's a DNA to being entrepreneurial
in the way you think about things
regardless of the setting that you're in
it's it's a way it has to do a lot with
asking the question why a lot it has to
do with always imagining and thinking
that there could be a better way not not
sort of accepting the status quo so it's
it's a mindset as much as anything from
my perspective in terms of
characteristics and personality traits
can I the Timex watch ad comes to mind
so it takes a beating and you know keeps
on ticking takes a lickin and keeps on
tickin and I think persistence and
determination or sometimes it's often
characterized as pigheadedness is I
think is an important characteristic
it's also choosing a voluntary lifestyle
of rejection much much in the way that
sales jobs often are so you know you
have a great idea you're very attached
to it you're passionate about it and you
have to have the thick skin to endure a
lot of people saying boy yeah that that
really sucks you know it doesn't that's
not really can't see how that would work
people telling you you're wrong the
joking aside I think kind of ultimately
what it's about is striking that right
balance between being passionate and
being in love with an idea or a vision
that you've created and at the same time
taking input and being open to influence
and those are very hard things to
balance I think one of the
the real kind of the fatal flaw if you
will of entrepreneurs is becoming so
attached to their idea that that they
don't kind of see what the world around
them is saying and kind of going right
into a wall sometimes or just kind of
not hearing so there's at the same time
you have to in the face of people saying
this is impossible you can't do it the
odds are against you have that passion
and conviction and determination to to
to pursue so it's a there's a lot of it
that is judgement and instinct that
comes into play which I would another
bias of mine just based on my own
personal experience is beginning in an
area that you have a particular insight
or domain and gives you that leg up and
because you always have to assume if
you're pursuing an idea that they're
going to be at least a dozen other smart
people in the world thinking of the same
idea so what's your advantage over them
and the domain expertise expertise at
least sort of my experience has played a
very important role in that it gives you
that unique insight as to what's flawed
about this industry or this area a lot
of people have great ideas and I think
actually not to denigrate that but I
think kind of having the great ideas
actually that not the hard part every
one many of us can envision sort of a
destination point it's it's knowing what
that journey looks like the sequence of
steps one must take to get to that
destination point that is actually a
very hard sort of you know art and
science so I'll stop there I'm Robert
Simon I went here to Stanford I have a
bachelor's and a master's degree in
Industrial Engineering and then taking a
class here at the Business School I
think which was still popular class
which is you write the business plan
class with another classmate from here
we incorporated a software company
called tea maker in 1983 so I was there
for the first two and a half years and
then left to start my own software
company yes Publishing that company was
developing text and graphics
applications for the Macintosh and
Windows and then it was subsequently
acquired by Lotus two
in 1989 I ran their West Coast office
for a couple of years then when they
wanted to move us all back east we
graciously declined and we started
another software company called virtual
corporation which was doing software for
the online spaces online information
retrieval of information from the online
services CompuServe MCI mail Dow Jones
news retrieval and in the internet that
company was acquired by Wall Street
access then went on to do a co-found
a hardware company called Navitus and
then went to Sierra ventures and then
while there incubated and then ran
another company which is a competitor to
PayPal called dot Bank and that was
acquired by Yahoo in 2000
so it's only called pay direct but I can
give you some perspective from the
entrepreneur side and then we can later
so talk about the venture side but I'm
to echo some of the comments that Julie
made is you have to almost be
schizophrenic you have to have open
mindedness yet focus so that that is
really the crux of it and you have to be
persistent and atom thick skinned for
sure the folks that started oldest
appalled brainer met with 40 different
venture capital firms before getting
anyone to agree to invest in their
company so 40 times
no thanks you're crazy until somebody
said oh maybe there's something here and
give them some money so you have to have
conviction and because it's an
all-consuming thing what you're doing
you're you know you're you're jumping
off a cliff with you and your partner or
your team and you're saying we have a
solution we've identified something that
no one else has
so that's brash and in the first degree
and then too you have to believe that
you can solve this problem and you have
to believe that you can solve it better
than anybody else and sooner than
anybody else because if you've
identified it then chances are somebody
somewhere else is also sort of thinking
about it but it's a lot of fun and you
you know and it's and it's all-consuming
so thank you my background is I have an
undergraduate degree in space mechanics
and propulsion and I love to say it
doesn't take a rocket scientist to make
beer or chocolate but if
I think when I'm got an MBA and did the
corporate thing I work for Xerox out of
school and then work right here
another big blue I had no desire to be
an entrepreneur
I liked my jobs and the big companies
and actually got into starting a company
relatively kicking and screaming I had a
friend that was a VC and said I see so
many business plans one of the two of us
saw our own company and I didn't want to
start a company I liked what I was doing
but I him heard him and we sat down I
think what got me really into this whole
idea of starting companies was the
process we went through we never talked
about what product or service we wanted
to do we talked about the goals of the
company that we'd start with what major
goals would be when we came up with
three and this is what got my juices
flowing the first three were whatever we
did product or service had to be
world-class gold medal-winning
top of the line something you're proud
of and passionate about the second goal
was we want to get in on the ground
floor of a new industry or a new segment
of an industry it's easy to say what how
do you find it and third the last goal
was probably the most important that is
whatever we did we had to have fun with
it let's not take ourselves serious and
treat the product or service with
reverence but everything else with your
reverence and once we got to those three
fundamental objectives I thought damn
this would be really cool if we could
achieve all three of these and we
continued the discussions and we came up
with some other key factors one I think
is very important for an entrepreneur
and that is you can't do it all yourself
and one of our key decisions upfront was
doing with my partner in myself do we do
we want to own a large piece of a small
company or a small piece of a large
company it was a very strategic question
and we opted let's go for a smaller
piece of a bigger company what that
means is let's get expertise in don't
believe you can do it yourself bring the
right people in whether they're
employees or consultants bring them in
paying for it and let
let's just ride the wave up don't let
your ego get in the way either my
partner or I could have run the company
but we realize time is money either one
of us might have been able to learn the
beer business but it would take some
time so instead we hired one of the best
consumer goods headhunters in the
country to find somebody from the beer
business who was going to come run the
company day to day don't let your egos
get in the way anyway that's kind of the
process we went to what does it take to
live this life you have to be able to
take the highs and the lows the highest
high and blow slow and be able to deal
with it three times four times a day
raising money even though you try and
start we have a consumer goods business
of the era now chocolate I'd say my
partner and I spent 80% of our time the
first year raising money rather than
building the business you can't focus on
what you have to focus on because you're
trying to raise money in our area of the
world there is no VC money matter of
fact we're finding that even private
equity firms that do consumer goods
don't do really stage anymore they won't
see 5 million revenues before they even
talk to you so you're spending all your
time trying to get money as best you can
one of the lowest lows we had a deal for
3 million of the day before we closed it
the company that was going to do it
decided not to do it and it takes the
wind out of your sails but soon
thereafter we got destiny product of the
Year award from the industry so you can
go hide a little very quickly but you
have to be able to deal with it the
employees we've hired have been great
people not everybody is cut out to go
through these highs and lows it drives
treasure nuts so you have to be willing
to have a thick skin
be able to be told no lots but there
aren't any good times to
my background was a designer have a
Potter for company business school here
and made my living is a very small
business guy selling what filling my own
work I got a disco network worked for
williams-sonoma for a few years did a
big startup funded by a large retail
company in the UK for three years and
came back and worked for nature company
and Smith and Holcomb before starting
design with the region in 98 and it
plays into something or I you know we're
all different I think that the
Entrepreneurship thing is probably a DNA
trait and and different characteristics
here but but to me that issue of in
terms of success going into some
industry some where you actually do have
some type of domain expertise and
passion is really key or I certainly
couldn't have done it without that
because the world is very competitive
and all throughout the fundraising
development of business your credibility
and your confidence as many ways related
to the intuitive way that you make
decisions and your knowledge of an
industry I think is really key as
luckily knows in the State of the Union
thing last night sort of thinking I
think just if someone's there wondering
if they're an entrepreneur it's probably
not the right place to be it's kinda
like if someone said oh I want to be a
politician but I'm not sure you're
either kind of got it to make
compromises to do what politicians do or
it should be in that you probably doing
it since you're a young age and I I
think of the entrepreneurial stuff kind
of the same way if you're really like
taking risks and probably have some
problems with authority and are more
interested in your own solution than
other people's solutions I think those
are good traits that this you brought up
about about being rejected
we were only rejected by 15 VC firms not
40 like the other guys but I don't think
it's part of not just group saying no
but you have to be willing to be laughed
at and and and feel comfortable with
that I mean there's a kind of an absurd
dimension to it but really not to take
yourself too seriously and then take
yourself
completely seriously but I think that
issue of you know failure not being an
option
you know failures are like a
mathematical certainty in new products
that's just the way it is
and if you're an artist or a write or
something like that you're so used to
making mistakes all the time it just
kind of comes with the turf so you don't
really view failures as personal
rejection or failure it's just part of
the process and because it the other
went to thinking about the just kind of
like a gambler analogy you know they say
the compulsive gamblers of people that
get more you for experience from their
from their winnings and tend to not
worry about their losses and people that
don't get will have the opposite they
feel so bad when they made a mistake
that they can't imagine I think that
entrepreneurs are a little bit that game
we profile where where the the buzz that
you get from getting something right and
really doing it really lists you up
there and that way you can deal with all
rejection and other issues all right so
what we like to do is take about 20
minutes to open up to questions and as I
reflected the answer so far they focused
quite a bit on personality issues and
maybe you have something more questions
about skills so just skills developing
the skills they're necessary so we have
about 15 minutes histories before we
move into the other side
well you know it's interesting I used to
say that it was absolutely essential and
part of that because it was because the
first few startups I did I worked with
people who had never been in a larger
company and I was very arrogant said
they don't know what they're doing
they're just learning it as they go
along so inefficient it's frustrating
you know kind of figuring it out day to
day but I have softened in that stance
and my perspective now is that I don't
think there is any part of what's so
magical and kind of no one's really
cracked the code on what it takes to be
a successful nor you know it can happen
any number of ways my own bias and I
would echo what Rob said I don't know
how I would have been able to do what
I've done we're not we're I not doing it
in area why have domain knowledge now
that I've done it a few times I now kind
of kind of abstract the skill set so you
know I could might be able to move into
another industry that I know less
because I I know kind of the framework
for how to get a company going off the
ground but starting out I don't know how
I would have pulled that off I think
that the larger company experience and I
started a mondo company telco Bell sells
huge huge company and you think how can
you be entrepreneurial for a hundred
thousand person company and the I think
it's important to go there it's a great
grounding to learn organizational stuff
management stuff skills you get access
to the best training the world but don't
stay too long that's my perspective you
know stay there long enough to get that
good grounding so that you know how to
work smart not hard and brute force your
way through it but get out of there
before you know you become the
organisation man as some people like to
refer to it so I I think it does give an
advantage but I wouldn't say that if you
don't have it you know you're not gonna
succeed I would separate the
Entrepreneurship there is continuing on
that theme separate the entrepreneurship
from the
main knowledge to start a new company
you have to have a someone in the team
has to have domain knowledge of the
problem that needs to get solved it may
or may not be coincident with the
founding team in the entrepreneur the
entrepreneurs it has that rallies
everyone around it and starts distilling
soup the useless is okay let's find a
you know much the same what's the same
process that that people went through
his group let's find an area let's apply
our business skills or general
organizational skills to solve it and
then let's find an area at which to
apply it to is for getting in the beer
business kind of it's kind of funny in
that I never drank beer till I was 29 I
hated beer I never drank until I met my
wife she drove me to drink and I think
every day my partner in the beer
business
has never had alcohol life but part of
our getting back to our objectives
finding its new segment that is on rise
and finding the craft beer segment was
fortuitous and we found that in looking
round for company number two which is
chocolate again part of the criteria was
getting the ground floor of the
high-growth segment really knew nothing
about fewer than Luton homebrewing
really knew nothing about chocolate but
in finding a space that's rapidly
growing relatively rapidly growing then
bringing some unique ideas to that
segment you can you can grow a good
business I like pita I've been drinking
all my life speak by personal experience
having worked for three companies that
were in the
million two hundred million fifteen to
twenty percent growth businesses in my
industry was absolutely key and having
made a bunch of entrepreneur mistakes
funded by a five billion dollar company
where I wasn't fundraising was really
valuable again the the credit that was
with credibility issues and also you you
know if your objective is a significant
business that may go public or something
like that to know what it feels like to
be working in a more mature company
that's operating really well and it has
two kind of the industry contacts and
you may pull a board member or other
people from that was was really
imperative I think for me and both
credibility and just a confidence in
where you're going not just where you're
beginning
yeah I'm a that's an excellent question
and I can't say that I handle rejection
well naturally so it has been a
developing kind of skill I think the no
is never easy and it doesn't for me it
doesn't just kind of roll off my back
but the most important thing I think the
know does as a first step is kind of
caused me to step back and say why is
this person saying no and really kind of
go deeper into it it's yeah and
resisting that temptation to dismiss and
say well you don't really understand
because you don't know as much about
this as I do so really kind of and then
then you know sort of I think moving
into problem solving motor and why are
they saying no sort of helps to move
past the initial kind of dejected
feeling of you know we were sailing boom
and then what happens to is it and I
think someone touched on it is that you
are you can imagine what success looks
like in the high and that keeps you
going and so you know the combination of
that and really getting the problem
solving and looking at as part of a
process not the ultimate judgment of
whether your idea is good or not or that
you're going to succeed or fail but
looking at it is so that step along the
process and say what can I learn from
this and then can and then where's my
course correction and then sort of
looking forward when no quick comment
when you're starting and I'll speak to
our experience where IT investors and
life science investor's and then when
when you're doing a start-up in that
field here you come up with a thesis
you've identified a problem and you hear
you coming up with an argument why you
have a solution for this problem why
there is a problem number two why what
you have
solution of the problem so you have to
do a lot of homework on your own to
convince yourself that you have
something to offer here to address this
pain point so you have to come up with a
lot of supporting data for yourself to
convince yourself and then others that
you're going to go out and fundraise now
you are going to get some notes but then
you have to look beyond that exam and
see if they are evaluating the same data
that you are see if they have the same
assumptions about the data that you do
and if they come to different
conclusions then you have to include
that in your analysis now they may have
different biases they may have different
assumptions about the market growth or
customer behavior and then you can then
you know argue away or rationalize those
but but you should take external
feedback absolutely and then you make
any on with it with Sam yet you may come
to different conclusions what we we
found is that again don't let ego get in
the way you you have to move quickly
the first speaker in the main auditorium
talked about your first idea probably
isn't going to work you have to tweak it
if you go in realizing that then being
told no isn't a no it's a learning
experience you don't you don't just take
it on on this face value but you learn
and what we've tried to done in both
companies is to get a product and
package to market knowing that
directionally using the baseball analogy
you want to get at least double you're
probably not going to get a homerun but
if you can get a double at least then
you're in the right direction and then
listen talk to your wholesalers your
distributors your meet your consumers
and find out what they like and don't
like and then go on a path to tweak it
and it might have to be major tweaks but
that's okay listen in here and if you
told no learn from it and integrated
then the great bunch of knows that that
I remember getting when we know when you
deal with when you visit
lunch product in your out with consumers
you get rejected most the time most
people don't buy your stuff small people
do incident to know that you can all
time but fundraising it's a different
thing and to me I had a long time to
develop a business plan and to test it
front a bunch of people and developed a
point where I'd heard all the knows and
I would approach a potential investor in
Sarasota
let me tell you the ten reasons why this
business might not work just based on
the input that I had so you're less
selling something than basically
reacting the stuff that you've heard and
then confidently going against me I just
add one more thing I would say I've
learned more from the nose than the
successes and I got to a point where I
had had a series of successes that I
didn't think this was hard it was like
you just show up things happen the first
time the the the know where the
difficulty came was the first time I
really sort of forced me dig in and say
what's going on here what's kind of the
broader dynamics I think you learn a lot
more from the nose um that's a great
question for everybody of course if you
like to direct your question particular
area for prodigious
I'd love to because I started the beer
company in 1986 with my partner and what
I'd love to say is I haven't worked in
20 years I've spent more hours doing it
then you can shake a stick at but it
doesn't feel like work I just jumped in
even though I'm late to beer drinking
and I've always talked ilat but the
passion drives it and when it doesn't
feel like a job it doesn't feel like
work and to me passion is everything but
you also want to extend that fast and
not only to the individual but everybody
in the company you wanted everybody
passion to feel like they're buying into
am really passionate about it and extend
that passion down to wholesale retail
and consumer that's sort of the price of
admission so that's why we haven't
really talked about it it's assumed to
be there it has to be there because
you're you know we'll get into the
lifestyle stuff you're working you know
I don't know eight you know pick your
number 12 to 14 hours a day and when
you're not working in the office you're
thinking about how you're gonna make
this thing successful so it's a
full-time job
you know 24 hours everyday every week
just one comment I was probably working
the same number hours in the corporation
so the trade-off wasn't that great in
terms of hours but in flight work yeah I
think it's it's it's not a job it's a
lifestyle choice in many ways right so I
think you you had out ahead passion is
assumed it is absolutely essential
because one of the key things I didn't
talk about I think around what does it
take to be successful I think the
ability to move people to your point of
view is very important and that passion
is infectious if you're passionate and
you have a vision
you know something that's either
value-driven or based on saying you know
this is we can do better than this
right and a passion around that then
that's the galvanizing force it's
infectious to the people that you're
trying to recruit to the company even to
investors and any sort of the whole
circle you want to touch and I think it
operates kind of subliminally it's kind
of like you know you can't be a business
without a brand it's your brand the
employees kind of sense it they pick it
up in phone conversations the investors
it's just kind of like is the price of
admission
we saw the opportunity but you know and
you're passionate about many things so
where I'm having the problem is what's
an efficient way for an entrepreneur to
come across both the idea and it's the
intersection of these and you know time
time is the most precious commodity
you can expend you know the rest of your
life looking at industries and spending
two years in the search party huge time
once it once it won't be an efficient
way for a person that has all these
entrepreneurial skills to come across
qualify and be able to find content but
once that thing is there the rest of the
process one of the things that we did
was again not to assume you know it all
yourself we actually exercised a great
opportunity we got to group the four
students at the Anderson School at UCLA
to help me quantify a potential business
in the world of barbecue it's another
passion of mine
we had three graduate students here help
us on the business plan for chocolate
what we what came out of these students
helping was they got a lot of cool
information on their own that in looking
for an opportunity that's going to be
growing turns out the barbecue business
didn't really show that that business
opportunity that we thought might be
there on the other hand in the world of
chocolate one of the interesting things
the students came up with was if you
look at different segments whether it's
beer or wine or chocolate or cookies or
crackers or ice cream one of the things
that came out of it was in the world of
premium which is the world we're
operating in every business area had at
least 20% of the overall revenue that
business and prequel premium in ice
cream is 40 percent with beer with the
craft beer movement that one from 10%
when we started to 20% today but
chocolate was only 11
and you could see even though smaller is
growing so having if you have access to
universities to have business students
work on interesting projects they can do
some homework or talk about your
perspective at the beginning well I kept
my day job I kept my day job for a while
and the key moment was when my partner
and I sat down after about nine months
in business and he saw that the business
had potential but really wasn't growing
because he had his day job and I had my
day job and that's when I decided one of
us is going to have to do it full time
and but we also jumped to conclusion
rather than one of us let's hire
somebody from the outside to run with
day to day I came on another year later
taking being the outside person rather
than the inside person but we minimize
risk by doing a part time and until we
got to the point where raise more money
and bring the expertise in yeah it's an
excellent question I think it has more
to do with the perception of risk than
the actual risk right so if you can
create a situation that you allows you
to perceive there's less risk which
means increasing your comfort zone you
know I I think into it my first startup
was a company called healthy on or Jim
Clark after starting Netscape pulled a
bunch of a set of SGI to start the
company and that felt my perception of
risk around that was lower but rather
than starting my own company kind of
ground zero and then gradually got into
you know more and more flying solo my
last company I incubated at a VC firm
where I was on entrepreneur residence so
again that feels like more of a safety
net than in your garage at this point my
husband is also a serial entrepreneur
where we've been self funding our own
company and that's been a complete
bootstrap model and so I think you can
kind of ease your way into that and sort
of think what is it about this it makes
me uncomfortable and how can I increase
that comfort level is it the fear of
failure is it the lack of income what
what is it the the I also think it's
great to do this when you're young
because you have less at stake the older
I get the more I know and the more I
have to you know sort of quote loose you
sort of get comfortable you get soft
whatever so I think it's it's it's
easier to do this when you're younger as
well
sure well I'll take a crack at it um
well it is always difficult to determine
people's motivations so some people
think it's you know money power or fame
and I think you'll find each of those to
some very degree in entrepreneurs some
people will start a company because they
do want to be rich and a lot of
companies were started that way late 90s
and 2000's with the anticipation of
making a lot of money quickly and they
were rudely surprised when it in fact
turn out to be much harder the
technology business to make money
quickly and easily some people just want
start company because they want to
change they're not happy with the way
the things being done and they want to
change they may come up with a solution
to a particular problem and that's the
the thing that's driving their passion
and we've used the words entrepreneurs
entrepreneurship is in the DNA that's
being a little bit flip and you have to
but you have to have some character flaw
in order to want to want to do you know
take on this inordinate amount of risk
and try to change other people's way of
thinking and doing so you have to you
have to have conviction and confidence
in yourself and your ability to do that
and that and that's more out of the norm
than the general population
I always certainly believe that you can
you can ingrained some of the skills
launched on entrepreneurship absolutely
but yeah I have to be a little bit
predisposed towards it
I would say if if you look at something
say wow there's an opportunity here
because of objectively assessing the
market but you're not passionate about
it that's a major to me that's a major
warning sign and it's like that's for
somebody else to capitalize but I I
would not pursue something I wasn't just
deeply passionate about and at the end
the converse is true if I'm passionate
you're passionate about something you
can't convince yourself analytically
that there's a real opportunity here
worth going you can't imagine an
equation that works from a business
standpoint then that's also a warning
sign so I'd say both are necessary
I would agree I get calls every day from
people want to start their business when
we started our beer company there may
have been 10 micro Brewers out there now
there are 1500 so it's a whole different
perspective on what the business
opportunity is and you have to integrate
the passion with the ability to really
have a differentiated bull product that
has some growth potential
I'll tell you I I love food and drink
obviously and so started two businesses
in those areas the the climate at retail
has changed over this 20-year period and
the ability to get on the Shelf is
harder and harder and harder why from
the distribution angle there are fewer
distributors as consolidation fewer
distributors mean bigger portfolios and
how to get a startup
attention within a distributor has a big
portfolio is very difficult retailers
have fewer buyers they represent more
product area so it is very little time
to talk to a buyer and then just the
time to get on the Shelf so the pain is
with a great idea getting from initial
acceptance from uh later retailer on the
shelf I give an example one chain that
we got approved in took fifteen months
to go from approval column shell just
everything just takes so long these days
in this business um there's a skate book
out there hey guys Jess we got called
the Purple Cow so it really gives with
some of the same issues that he was
talking about that remarkable really
remarkable products or ideas are really
in demand right now and those that don't
solve some fundamental problem probably
dealing with our lack of time and a
oversaturation that we have with
different options to me are challenging
so I see different opportunities out
there all the time but I think that that
large one about really the specialized
nature
you're doing and having some
extraordinary remarkable characteristics
you're really key rather than something
that we put enough money behind it we're
going to make them market aware of this
or relying on things that are based on
cost efficiencies and economies of scale
in for an entrepreneurial level and the
gift of something does far more kind of
real strong kind of character that
you've really dependent again already to
talk about what it's like to be an
entrepreneur and eminence and awards and
also sort of time we've addressed that
as well but if you like to hear comments
prepared at events and topic what is the
right time
what is the best style and then we'll
continue with questions is there anyone
who would or you've already addressed in
your questions maybe I'll pull up on
some of the comments that you already
made on ones the right time and getting
back to your question on risk so I would
separate the risk on a sort of personal
risk and then financial risk and we've
talked about ways of mitigating
financial risk which is you know keep
your day job so on the financial side
that you sort of look at it as one end
of the spectrum you have the luxury of
personal assets or family assets or a
spouse that's able to support you while
you potentially don't have income for
the next 12 to 18 months the other end
of the spectrum is you're unemployed and
so your opportunity cost is zero and you
look at going back maybe 15 20 years
with the downsizing in Southern
California of the lot of the military
contractors a lot of very talented
engineers found themselves out of work
you know we were working on you know at
JPL or TRW and there was a huge increase
subsequently in entrepreneurship and new
startups down there so you know the
financial risk can be you know one of
two categories on the person or you just
have to say am I willing to put myself
out there and risk a personal failure
and ridicule for what I believe to be is
a
a reasonable idea and then you got to
follow that up with compassion if you're
not totally committed to it people will
people that you work with or your
potential investors will smell that and
they'll see oh man you know he's giving
a shot but you know when things turn
things get tough he's probably is going
to cut and run you know and it's be very
difficult to build support build a team
around you if you're not totally
committed
I think getting some experience in the
larger company environment is helpful
what it allowed me to do was to realize
that I had to do something different
because I was sort of bored stiff and
unlike the night Pete I didn't keep a
day job I just
necessity for that sort say you know
life is looking a little shorter here
and you really want to do something they
believe in so I left the job in sold a
house and gave myself 12 months to write
a business plan and do you know
thoroughly research a market but I
really didn't have any other option
because I just needed it sort of
personally and spiritually
- what are the differences well I kind
of mentioned part of it before in
consumer goods there is no funding there
are no VCS there are no private equity
firms so it's all personal and angel in
making contacts and one of the
strategies we have with the beer company
and with the Chocolate Company is okay
you can do your spreadsheets and figure
out how much money you're going to raise
1 million 5 million whatever the number
is but put that aside and the strategy
we took was let's say we can only raise
half a million the recording requires a
million or whatever the number is let's
come up with a timeline and deliverables
and say if we raise half a million these
are the things we're going to deliver so
we could show we can meet what we're
delivering and in the world of beer we
had five rounds of financing we're a not
only that many times we couldn't raise
that much our first round was twenty one
thousand our second rounds fifty
thousand but we always have deliverables
to say we're going to meet what we say
we're going to meet and I think if
you're not going to do tech with VCS you
guys really kept take the approach
you're never going to raise enough money
initially so do is step by step and show
that you can do it you can say I think
there are some second-tier smaller firms
that play in those fields that you can
network into through
investors and other people that
certainly been our experience but I
think they're probably okay so wearing
the venture capital hat now and how do
we evaluate a passion of an entrepreneur
one of the things we like to see is if
they've been moonlighting on this
particular project for some period of
time if they aren't able to take
financial risk of quitting your job if
they've been working on it for the last
more than three months that shows a
level of understanding of the problem
and maybe some interaction with
customers and maybe they've gone so far
as to build a prototype so those are all
very positive and concrete steps yeah I
would have looked for an articulation of
the problem from the customers
perspective you don't really know what
you have in terms of product until
you've got three or four customers but
you have to get the begin the process of
talking to customers from the beginning
that's the last night I learn in it and
we see it repeatedly on the venture side
one of the things that would be a red
flag is is sort of like well if we don't
get this thing funded you know we're
going to try something else you know the
lack of conviction because i'm i as the
investor i'm counting on you to be the
domain expert and to be the most
knowledgeable about the problem i'm
never going to know as much as you do so
I'm trusting you to do your homework and
it's bail to kind of leap of faith on
our side too
we've got pizza idea the responses
question about that you have the
expertise but we don't have some of the
things that we've seen successfully and
then partially successfully are the
couplings between the business school
students and School of Engineering it's
been successful here at Stanford some of
the other places that often couples the
business school students has a passion
for starting a business with a initially
a technical domain expert maybe from the
School of Engineering now they have a
technology they don't know where to
apply it so until you get all three
pieces together you don't really have
the ingredients for a potentially
successful startup so then together the
team of technologists and entrepreneur
have to find the problem for which this
is the ideal solution that's often where
things fall down and that can take
anywhere between six months to 18 months
yeah lots of times you have technologies
searching for a problem and until you
find the problem then you really don't
know what we got we have an investment
in our portfolio in a nano technology
company in Berkeley called nano mix and
they've got they're one of the leaders
in carbon nanotubes okay great what do
you do with carbon nanotubes well we
don't know exactly yet they're the first
application that they've got is is a
sensor very low cost
highly sensitive set so you take these
nanotubes you take two here you put one
across then you paint the one middle
with some with some biomaterial that you
know can tell if there is carbon dioxide
or ammonia or something and then it's an
incredibly sensitive sensor that you
low cost or you can take these nanotubes
and store hydrogen with them now the two
hugely different applications in
different applications but you have to
figure out what are the initial best
avenues highest potential
yeah I'd say there's a world of
difference between having a technology
and having a product world of difference
and you know the two ways you come at it
and I think he did a good job of kind of
talking about the intersection is and
you know the Silicon Valley is notorious
for inventing technology without having
really thought about where it's going to
be applied you know we came up this
thing we think it's really cool you know
if we build it they will come so you can
have that start with the technology but
then figuring out what problems are
going to solve what how is it going to
manifest as a product is going to be
sort of the next sort of challenge and
proof point you you're faced with the
other way to come at it is identify a
market pain point a whole connect to a
customer base who might need this what
do they need it for and then back into
it say how would we go about building
that and figure out what technology to
apply but no matter where you start you
sort of have to get their section to do
I think again you know I'm biased by my
tech experience but I think that what
consumer actually companies do much
better than technology companies do is
get close to the customer where we're
notoriously bad at sort of living in our
own bubble thinking how cool what we've
done is and and not really talking to
the customer I think consumer companies
do much better job of that and I think
on that if you're at the center of the
business you're the entrepreneur there
you figure out what your shortcomings
and recruit for that on the other side
and it may be something that is
resistance to understanding customers or
weakness on my side operations and
logistics and some of that hard core
analysis so I think you can offset
whatever you have if your analytic about
it and you know support yourself with
different person
yeah um yeah but it wasn't just sacred
becomes you know I'm just not a meeting
guy businesses get to a certain size and
spent a lot of time I'm just too antsy I
like doing and doing other things I was
very fortunate and having a couple of
different marketing positions and then
doing a big startup funded by a very
large company where I got general
management experience three years out of
business school and created and had an
extraordinary failure over 3-year period
of time and that was invaluable in both
my book my confidence and comfortability
with that stuff so I was able to make
some serious mistakes on somebody else's
dollar let's follow up to that which
hasn't brought up this sort of lifestyle
you have to think you know when you
start your first do your first startup
you have a lot of your personal emotion
and being invested in it now one thing
that will help you with that a little
bit is is that realizing this won't be
the first and only time you do so this
won't be the only time you do this ok so
once you go down this path whether it's
successful or unsuccessful you're most
likely to do it again that helps with a
whole host of things you know it helps
with the rejection it helps with you
know you know I've got all my eggs in
this one basket it's got to be
successful and I have to be focused and
puke imagine you have to give it all but
this isn't going to be you know the life
and death of you as a person so you're
going to do it again the first time
might work out might not work out the
second time you'd be better at it third
time you go - better yet again and it's
an incremental improvement process and
then if you keep that in mind then you
know kind of world's not so not so tense
I started my first 40 years ago anybody
said and you had passion for something I
think what has occurred is that we only
did that in preparation for the panel so
think about really what you can do and
what you're good at doing yourself and
I would even take that one step further
say it I think as a matter of whether I
can't I can or cannot run a company it
the question I think Pete spoke to this
a bit it's am I the best person on the
planet that can run this company or is
there somebody else who could run it
better because time and money are your
enemy so do you want to go through the
learning curve the cycle and put the
business at risk as you learn that job
or is there somebody who can come in and
do it in a faster better
Charles sort yeah if I think that's an
excellent question because one of the
key if I were to attribute sort of
success to one key thing you know
assuming you figure it out that you're
really an entrepreneur and all this have
we been talking about is it's about the
people at the end of the day most
companies don't end up doing what they
start out doing they may do some variant
of it they may do something completely
different it's a circuit to dispatch to
finding kind of your way to a repeatable
model that's sustainable so it's not
about the idea necessarily that's not
the most important thing the model can
change if they you know based on that so
it's not about that it's really the
constant is the people and the first few
people in a company and I learn this
lesson over and over again with each
company really set the tone and the
culture of the company I mean the
entrepreneur at the end of the day
doesn't kind of to the greatest impact
but those first few people as a group
how they function as a group really sets
the tone for the company and that has
kind of a lasting impact so you know
what I learned to do more and more each
time is be more and more thoughtful
about what kind of people do I want to
the company I used to only think about
it from a domain skill set standpoint
but what I really sort of realized is
you know are these the kind of people
from a value system standpoint that have
values that are consistent with what I
want to create here and that will
support sort of the mission in terms of
getting them on board I think it really
comes down to again that skill and this
is why you see a lot of folks who have
successful charismatic leaders right so
the ability to move someone to your
point of view and infect them with that
passion that you have tapping into to
something is that because that's what's
going to cause somebody to do things
like take a pay cut or leave a secure
job and take a risk it's because there's
something an emotion
feel that your path day two so I think
that's very important you're having the
real clear sense of you know how are we
going to change the world make it a
little bit you know a better place or
you know solve some really important
problem and that vision and that
aspiration is a real key driver to
getting those folks on board one of the
people people are everything we when we
hired people we weren't necessarily
looking for high level of skill that in
a small area of expertise we were
looking for motivated people who are
willing to take on any and all
challenges sure they had to do the job
they were hired to do but we love to
encourage people to say hey nobody's
looking at this thing can I go look at
it and you say absolutely and you allow
people to stretch possibly fail
hopefully gain but it motivates people
internally to say I'm not just
pigeon-holed into one area I can I can
go after a lot of different things and
one of our product proudest things is to
two people we hired right out of college
became VPS just because they were so
willing to take on new assignments the
other thing we did to motivate people
was one of the niches we wanted to make
in the beer world and now the chocolate
world is being the educators when you do
something Premium a lot of people
confused by what the heck all these
things are to become educators we wanted
everybody to feel comfortable that they
knew what they were talking about
including the receptionist it's amazing
how many people would call in and ask
reception it's a question about your
product but we want to show that we're
experts so every employee had a passive
ear test it's not just drinking but but
we wanted to have people really get
passionate about the product you know
the product inside and out so that's
what we did
your your relationships that you're
relying on all the time
in periods of failure and needing
feedback and all that stuff are part of
the business there may not be a specific
mentor but the deal of a calling up and
knocking on the doors and really being
persistent of the most talented people
in your industry and the people they
respect the most and using them for
feedback all the time I think is
absolutely essential II just it's not a
situation if you think that you're in
this thing alone and not getting advice
of people to know a lot more than you I
think you'd be in a critical spot or we
use our board we have a small board for
people in the U 5 as we grew it knows a
great forum for bouncing ideas off of
getting nice and long stretch in other
areas so in a constructive raised money
or even prior raised money you can have
a board of directors or a board advisors
even from in a corporation you can
identify someone as a mentor but when
you're just starting out on your own you
can you can also find and pick your own
mentor people are very willing to mentor
to help to coach to guide someone who's
starting a company and now you have a
huge range of options and you just pick
someone who you think is an expert in
the area that you want to go into or
have some business experience you just
gonna blow yourself on to them that's
part of your job your charm and your
passion here's it hi I'm starting in
this crazy company in this new area what
do you think and you know and you get
them through your infectious personality
and optimism to spend an hour with you
an hour a week an hour a month or
whatever it is and they're now your
mentor one of your advisors yeah
mentoring played a very important role
in in my sort of getting to be an
entrepreneur I had mentors when I was
working large companies who really
encouraged me and I never had a normal
job I think kind of cleared the way I
said you know go do what you think needs
to be done and I think that that
encouraged me and helped me to tap into
a lot of the skills that I needed to be
an entrepreneur
and times when you say I can't do that
you're intimidated you know they would
be there to say yes you can go do it so
that was essential for me and and some
of those folks have continued to play a
role as I've moved into starting
companies as as as advisors that you go
back to and it's sort of when you're
struggling with something or for
validation and support I think that's an
important thing I've seen entrepreneurs
kind of do it solo and I think that's
very hard it's hard enough as it is that
makes it so much harder in a building
that support network of people that are
going to advise you both professionally
emotionally personally on all those
levels ends up being a very important
reinforcement and I think it's a really
talented people after the past success
no one has a lot of times if you're
really clear about I know you don't have
a lot of time here the quick things that
I need to know you can we can win over
people by a respect for who they are and
they're very generous with their with
the things that they actually know
not being able to have 20 hobbies I
inadvertently made a sacrifice around
family and friends and it happens
doesn't happen in a dramatic way it
happens in a you know kind of step at a
time
can't make it to this can't make it to
that way and then one day you wake up
and you know you realize that you know
people have sort of moved on with their
lives so and that's that's a regret that
I had at a certain point in my career
and then I tried to take the with my
last time I said I'm going to take a
life balanced approach I don't want to
get into that point again and I realize
it's quite impractical because again
time and money are your enemy so you
know if you're taking this life work
balance a sort of approach at least if
you're in a competitive industry you
know the other guys aren't and it's
taking you more money to get there so I
think it's very hard I haven't cracked
the code on it too to not do this in a
24 by 7 intense way and that means you
know time and energy or zero sum that
means you don't have the time and energy
to do other things and I think that's
that's a I say a perennial struggle the
challenge of being an entrepreneur
there's lots of stories in the valley
about casualties on a personal
relationship side either deferred or
your marriage and it just falls apart
because one of the other partners
working 20 hours a day and just doesn't
have time for you to the family or the
spouse so it's a balance and you know
finding ways to incorporate your support
structure into what you're doing while
making a ballad
but there it's absolutely it's
absolutely an issue in the second
company my wife is our cocoa bean
counter so
we get to spend time together any that
work I did community's an analogy of
having triplets I don't have triplets
but uni you you know you can even kind
of know what it's like to have a kid and
then you have some friends that have
twins or something but if for a fast
growth kind of startup that they like
the third thing is just it sort of
beyond what you could really kind of
imagine and all those things that you
will you know sleep deprivation and
total obsession and all that stuff and
you really there's a you know three or
four year period where you have to
suspend judgment about what's going to
happen and then that's where I sort of
believe that I think is passion things
key because having a real interest in
what you're doing gets you through those
areas and if you're standing back and
wondering that might be a little tougher
I would say at least for me there's has
always been an aha moment and it's it's
just kind of when you know the different
pieces click together and you can
imagine a way for this to sort of really
be successful but you don't stay there
right yeah it's it's transient and then
you know you wake up next anytime I'm an
idiot this is never going to work and so
you go back and forth but there is kind
of I can remember distinctly the moment
I said I had the idea occurred to me
that okay there could be something here
and and that's a memorable moment I've
had the same sort of experience here
you're kicking around a couple different
ideas you're exploring one particular
idea and then at some point it's enough
to put you over over the edge and then
pass the hurdle you may walk will add to
that but but at some point go okay this
is strong enough to actually pull the
team together and get going
my metric on it having tried a lot of
different ideas and being that there's
with the smart people in the industry
the really smart did not return your
phone calls something something that
happens when you're seeding an idea and
it's kind of like this really gifted
people can say yeah okay maybe had two
more questions
I would say it's an edge oh we have so
much birds that come into our office and
they say yeah in 2000 where you start
this company we raise 50 million bucks
and we raise another 55 spent hundred
million bucks it's gone yeah so that's
not a positive but you look beyond wait
and then you ask the questions you know
what what what learnt what was learned
from that experience both by you
personally what were the challenges that
you faced what were the incorrect
assumptions and if and if and if I don't
think they make sense or no one else
around the table things that make sense
think so this guy's a knucklehead we're
not going to go down this path again but
if it seems reasonable and it was a
reasonable no one no one's going to hold
it against you for taking a reasonable
path and then you know you had an
experience I would be nice to go to a
positive one but it fortunately the
attitude in this valley here is amazing
and it's not held against you in any way
really yeah I think I think there is a
general a lot of wonderful things about
the valley and I think there's a general
feeling that you know if you've had a
failure you've learned a lot I mean
there's a positive attitude toward and
that you know how did that failure come
about and you know how much money did
you burn along the way and you know sort
of all those things come into play of
course but I think this is probably the
industry you know based on sort of my
knowledge that I would say has one of
the healthiest attitudes about failure
are you doing very sure
our firm invests in in information
technology and life science company so
we're more product oriented some venture
firms like service businesses so the
pluses and minuses and then I'm not
going out I'll consider software as a
service a product company ok less so
that although it's the kind of a
combination so a service business to me
are like you know telco operator or
something like that often the
characteristics of the service business
are lower barriers to entry it may be a
regional play and you are the purchaser
of technology from the market which is
good because you get to pick the best
technologies the challenge for us as
investors we like to have that unfair
competitive advantage that's defendable
and you don't often see that in us on
the service side but if you do then
those are great characteristics ok and
then conclude I would really make plans
for real bright a question member very
thought-provoking I would also like to
pop up sure and please go a fan
have succession in here and then only a
joke Robert Peter up for providing
answers that were really good aluminum
with the experiences for Bundoran
principles